as you said I think one of the big goals
of xai is to understand the universe yes
that's how simple three-word uh
Mission um if you look out far into the
future do you think on this level of
physics the very edge of what we
understand about physics do you think it
will make discoveries sort of the
sexiest discovery of them as as we know
now sort of uh unifying general
relativity and quantum mechanics so
coming up with a Theory of Everything do
you think it could push towards that
direction almost like theoretical
physics discoveries if an AI cannot
figure out new physics um it's clearly
not equal to humans let alone nor has
surpass humans because humans have
figured out new physics they just you
know physics is just understanding you
know deepening one's insight into how
reality works and then
uh then then then this engineering which
which is inventing things that have
never existed mhm now the the range of
possibilities for engineering is far
greater than for physics because you
know we once you figure out the rules
the universe uh that that's that's it
you've discovered things that already
existed but from that you can then build
Technologies with that are really almost
Limitless in the uh variety and cap you
know it's like once you understand the
rules of the game properly and we do
with current physics we do at least at a
local level understand how physics works
very well where our ability to predict
things is incredibly good like quantum
mechanics is the degree to which quantum
mechanics can predict outcomes is
incredible um that was my that's myot
hottest class in college by the way my
my my senior quantum mechanics class was
harder than all of my other classes put
together to get an AI system a large
language model to to um
reliably be as reliable as quantum
mechanics and physics is very difficult
yeah you have to test any any
conclusions against the ground truth of
reality reality is the ultimate judge
like physics is the law everything else
is a
recommendation I've seen plenty of
people break the break the laws made by
man but none break the laws made by
physics it's a good test actually if
this
LM uh understands and matches physics
then you can more reliably trust
whatever it thinks about the current
state of politics in some sense and it's
also not not the case currently that uh
even that its internal logic is not
consistent um so especially
um with these with the approach of like
just predicting a token predict token
predict token it's like a vector sum you
know you you're summing up a bunch of
vectors but you can get drift um so as
those a little bit of error a little bit
of error adds up and by the time you are
many tokens down the path uh you're it
doesn't make any sense mhm so it has to
be somehow self-aware about the drift it
has to be self-aware about the drift and
then look at the thing as a gal as a
whole and and say it does it have
coherence as a whole MH
so you know when when authors write
books that they they will write the book
and then they'll go and revise it you
taking into account you know all the end
and the beginning and the middle and and
uh re to achieve coherence so that it
doesn't end end up in a nonsensical
Place mhm maybe the process of revising
is what yeah reasoning is and then
that's the process of rising is how you
get closer and closer to truth maybe you
like uh at least I approached it that
way you just say a bunch of
first and then you get it better you
start a and then you get you
create a draft and then and then you and
then you iterate on that draft um until
it has has coherence until it's it all
adds up basically